with us this morning is Pat Cullen the
RCA inter General Secretary and chief
executive good morning thanks for
joining us
um
before we talk about the strike wherever
he actually where have you actually got
to the negotiations
um well
put simply and we aren't in negotiations
I have made many attempts on behalf of
not just the 300 000 nurses that have
been balloted but the 500 000 plus
nurses that I represent and
unfortunately this government hasn't
engaged with the Royal College of
Nursing as yet when you say they have
engaged and and uh do you mean that
you've asked for a meeting and um
whoever happened to be Health secretary
at the time said no I'm not talking to
you well the last Health secretary that
I'd contact with was Sergeant Javed and
since then we have made multiple
attempts to try and engage with the
health secretary and the two the current
one and the previous one that was very
short lived and both of those people
have not as yet met with the Royal
College of Nursing but presumably the
the actual employer here anyway is not
to read copies is now the health
secretary but the NHS presumably you are
talking to NS NHS managers of course
we're talking about and where have you
got to with them well of course the NHS
managers will say very clearly to me
that it's not within their gift to
um negotiate with me on pay for their
employees which are our nurses so I'm
bounced back to government and that's
right that's absolutely right those
employers do not have the authority uh
to actually negotiate because agenda for
change sits at um which is the pay
framework for our nursing staff sits
within the domain of government to make
those decisions
what um what is it that you want
um what what is your sales of central
demand well first of all for nurses to
be paid a fair and decent wage that's
what we're asking for and our ask is
five percent above the rate of inflation
that's very clear it's not about nurses
um being greedy uh it's not about
wanting the same um preferential
treatment that was given to the bankers
and others by this government we're
asking for them to be repaired a fair
and decent wage so that we can retain
them in the Health Service looking after
our passions well
um let's leave the bankers aside because
they're not paid by the government
they're not paid by the taxpayer five
percent above inflation this morning is
14.9 percent
that's quite a hefty rise
well Trevor you did mention the bankers
but if you looked and um of course we
attended the Conservative Party
Conference and we listened very
carefully to what they say and it does
seem that those people like bankers and
others are very carefully looked after
what we have seen very clearly from this
government is that they haven't managed
to actually recognize that they cannot
have a Health Service without nurses we
heard this morning from ministers coming
on this program and talking about how
they're going to deliver on their as
their B's their says and their days and
what I want to say to each and every one
of them they'll deliver on none of those
if they do not understand there's an n
in the alphabet because each one of
those depend on nurses we deliver
nothing in Health and Social care
without having a nurse and yet they have
just seemed to not understand that they
need to understand that there's a nen in
the alphabet and they need to respect
nurses if they want to retain them in
the Health Service if we can stop our
nurses having to leave the Health
Service and indeed social care to find
jobs in supermarkets in restaurants and
other places that they can pay their
bills I think that's an incredible
indictment on any minister to sit here
and not actually recognize what they are
doing to the Health Service and to
patients do you um are you getting any
more mileage if I can put it that way
from the devolved administration's
Scotland is a separate negotiation I I
guess as it would be Northern Ireland
well certainly in Scotland there was a
higher percentage and pay award
um granted this time right it certainly
didn't come anywhere near a what nurses
require in order to make a decent living
and this isn't they're not asking for
um as I've said golden handshakes out of
this they're not they're asking for a
decent living wage and they're not
getting that so no government and of
course we know the situation in North
than Ireland so we'll not go there but
as yet none of the default
administrations have come up to the
standard that we expect them to for our
nursing staff so you'll be going back to
the Scots and Stormont when when there
is a government installment and saying
that nurses need a bit more we've
already done that yes and of course in
those three hundred thousand ballot
papers that went out they went out right
across the UK not just in England well
let's talk about what that means
um we don't have any experience of a
nurse's strike how would that work I
mean what if you walk out
what happens to patients who are
in intensive care patients who are going
to be dehydrated patients who need their
dressings changed okay well actually we
do have
um experience of a nurse's strike and I
had the privilege but actually the
sadness of leading the first nurses
strike in 103 years history of this
college in late
2019-2020 in Northern Ireland when we
actually had no government
um and during that time what I would say
to each person and member of the public
listening this morning are nursing staff
and I am a nurse of 42 years will never
walk away from you and during that
strike in Northern Ireland we did not
walk out on our passions we made sure
our patients were still cared for now of
course there will be disruption because
the clues in the title it is about
withdrawal of labor but we still
continue to provide life preserving
Services during that time and there are
certain services that we will absolutely
never withdraw labor from but
what action would you say because if I
may put it straight you can't have it
both ways you can't say that we are
going to hold the government's feet to
the fire but actually if it becomes
difficult for anybody we're going to
look after them
well there's life preserving services
that we will always continue to provide
because we are a regulated profession we
will absolutely not just don't tools and
leave our patients and abandon them we
haven't done it to date and we'll not do
it now we certainly will not and but
there will be a withdrawal of nursing
staff and we have very clear
um clinical protocols in place about how
we manage that on a day of a strike
about the number of staff that will
remain to provide services for our
patients and those that will then
obviously that you will see should the
time come and that will be seen on
picket lines and that will be managed
very carefully and very safely and the
other thing that I will say that during
the strike in Northern Ireland which
lasted for eight days and again if our
nurse's ballot and for strike action in
any of our UK countries as we move
forward in November we will cause no
further or additional risk to patients
that's already created as a consequence
of this government turning their back on
nursing as we be stamped well if I mean
can we be specific about the
World midwives for example be involved
in this action in Northern Ireland we
certainly didn't withdraw midwives at
the time of our strike action no we
didn't and the nurses with ambulances
waiting three four five six seven eight
and yes and I go back to the point that
I made in the a the B the C and the d
none of those will be will will be
delivered absolutely not and why do we
see those ambulances queued up at the
minute we see them queued up because
there's not the nursing staff to look
after those passions that are in the
backs of those ambulances and what an
indictment on a society to actually keep
patients our elderly patients in the
backs of ambulance simply because we
have turned our back on nursing staff
and finally if I may ask briefly what
will you do if the government says we're
going to treat nurses like police
officers and make it unlawful for them
to strike
well we heard a lot this morning about
democracy didn't we and this is the
Democratic right of the worker to
actually first of all belong to a Trade
union and then have representation and
why are we representing our nurses
because there's no government speaking
up for them at the minute and again that
would be another nail in the coffin for
this government to say that they're
actually going to silence the workers
the people at the front line the
clinical staff looking after a patients
day in Daily so I think that would be a
very sad day if we move to that position
and certainly our Royal College of
Nursing will have something to say about
it pat Garland thank you very much
indeed thank you